alors on va faire une interview où joue
ou et je vais vous citer des noms
et vous allez me donner le guennic donc
moi je donne les noms vous donnez le
limitateur bouge pas
bien alors jusqu'à giscardisme et
modernité céline dion ma mère irène est
que jack lang
quel bel homme gérard holtz mobilisez
vous patrick bruel
si tu me quitterait je souffrais
philippe de villiers je sais contre
maastricht contre les accords de
schengen suivent à la c'était charmant
petit coin cabane au fond du jardin
sur lci elle s'appelle en eau du alan
débile c'est parfait jean d'ormesson au
figaro jean luc godard le cinéma la
différence ans a sévi sur le cinéma
c'est qu'au cinéma on lève les yeux
pierre bellemare ce gué 3,15 fort il va
venir
oui je le souhaite mais on va le vendre
quinze jours par les guides cube et
chirac pour finir mais ça c'est jeu
2 [ __ ] est laurent gerra alors je vis
donc à tous nos amis que laurent gerra
est là marimi jusqu'au 28 mai c'est ça
c'est ça et ensuite alors bonne nouvelle
à sa reprend au casino de paris à la
rentrée mais on a on a réussi passé
c'est tout c'est tout chaud mais bat
pour pas laisser trop de gens sur le
carreau d'aller si les deux projets
trois semaines au au casino de paris
masse salariale gérer ça me fait plaisir
que je suis bien sur scène mais vraiment
et en plus je crois que quand on revient
samedi marc hé oui c'est bien ça se
ressent et puis vraiment c'est un vrai
bonheur pour que sur la tournée la scène
tout va bien donc on va comme dit de
leur domicile mais s'est bien marré